with the division less than a week away
Ubisoft massive has started to outline
its DLC plan the game will offer both
free content in the form of updates and
something the developer is calling tasks
and challenges as well as paid
expansions the first of these updates is
called incursions and it will be
available in April this is described as
a new challenging endgame activity
developed specifically for squad play
rave like missions maybe Ubisoft said
this update will also add one of the
community's Most Wanted features loot
trading allowing players in the same
group to trade loot collected during a
co-op game session the next update
called conflict will come in may and
will add new dark zone features after
that the paid DLC will start rolling out
the first expansion underground will be
available in June this first major
expansion lets players explore the
Uncharted underworld of New York City
players will chase deadly enemies with
up to three other agents through an
endless maze of tunnels and subways two
more expansions will follow underground
survival which will be available in the
summer and last stand which will come in
the winter the division launches on
march eight the games recently concluded
open beta attracted 6.4 million players
across pc playstation 4 and xbox one
representing a new record for a new ip's
beta on new generation consoles
you